I don't see anything.
Good. Good. I made extra sure that...
and have anything on my face.
But now you're mad.
This thing was--
all over the place. But it was that good.
Good. Yeah.
and stuff. It's perfect.
Yeah.
Bye.
Let's talk about this.
Uh-huh.
Let me just break up.
Your email here.
I want to go through this with you.
I mean,
And this is what we have is template boiler plate.
stuff here. So, and it's
in really in 20 years.
is really mention these.
items. It's all.
good it's all good.
And I'll tell you my
thoughts on it.
Hang on a second, you'll see me.
[inaudible]
Bye, Dr. Amber Hong Kong.
Isn't that cool?
All right, so here are the comments that were that.
we're put together.
And I get it, you know, you're just.
We want to do your due diligence and review all.
the contracts and all that stuff. So here's the thing. So number
security account access. So this is just a general statement.
So this service is predicated.
on us being able to move data level.
electronically. If we don't have user names, passwords, and
security answers. We can't do stuff.
So that's why we put that in there.
I don't think.
For me, it's fine.
I'm not going to say.
You know hey contract law you didn't give us this
Because the reality is we just can't do our work.
unless we have that. So certainly given us
I'm just reading because I got four monitors here.
Certainly, giving us the--
It can't delegate it access.
That's cool, that's fine.
as long as I can connect.
And in the office here here, now I'm joking.
on the almonds that were in the protein market.
Sorry about that.
as long as when we're doing our work, here's the bet.
But we do our work because we got so many monthly clients.
It's like when we sit, like we got a refresh.
stuff or there's a token there's a you know the tokens kind of
So then if we don't have to, we don't have to.
have, you know, a user, a password,
you know, and some kind of access.
that can automatically send an MFA.
They hold to you.
then we're struggling here.
So-- so--
That's what that is.
I'm not worried about I account
It's cool with us just as long as we can do our work.
(music)
Absolutely. Rice and guard, guard real.
change orders. Additional expected.
Okay, so here's the thing.
We work based on the amount of work that's involved to us.
So when you present us with additional work
So the reality is sometimes we just absorb it.
But other times, you know, will...
Well, if there's going to be a significant--
If it can change, you'll know in advance.
Wait, like, what?
price increase, we do price increases.
Here's the reality.
this. We use vendors they're
our prices and at times we're going to raise our prices too.
Inflation is two to three percent and this is, you know,
Maybe you learned something here, maybe you already know it and it.
and I apologize, it sounds like being being.
or my pulpit.
We all have to raise prices.
And we have to look at the manual because the reality
is if you start your business, Teddy.
and your price today is the same as it is in 10 years and it's
our CPI is three and a half percent. You're losing.
35 cents and you're going backwards in 10.
So we all have price increases.
We'll send out price increases every year, probably two.
three sometimes depending upon the complexity.
There might be more that's involved during the year, and we think that
that is going to be consistently part of the relationship.
So you might see a five or seven percent increase.
And when...
What happens is we send out an email and you know what?
If you're not happy you call me send me
an email, whatever. We talk about it.
The worst thing I don't ever want to see anybody go but...
But if they're, hey, we don't think.
I think that this is right.
You increased our fee by 10.
10%, despite the fact that we gave you two more.
rentals and we're filing two more states.
We don't.
that that's right so we're leaving. If you saw
Our arrangement is not a long-term arrangement.
It's 30 days.
And you know what, for all I care--
It could be one week.
It could be two weeks.
I just put something.
in there. You know, if you want to leave tomorrow, then you'll
leave tomorrow and just you know we finish off whatever the month is.
And that's it. So that's how that works.
expedited processing. That's work.
that's like this is non-recurring,
where you call me up.
say oh my god and I gotta buy this warehouse
I need this information by Friday.
I know you're busy, but you literally have to spend
a day and a half working for me.
So, right, you are not everything. I'm gonna...
Stadium. All right, well this is what it's gonna be and you're gonna
I'm throwing a...
and let's figure it out.
Or you'll say yeah.
All right.
Where do you want--
it is send the suitcase full of money.
So that's that third community.
locations with bags to turn his roof. So this array
things, but does not work with, we're not.
You know, I try to keep the scope leg real tight, just like you're going.
going to with all your clients.
This isn't, well,
Ed said that he would talk to me like any other person.
time during the year. Well, then he could probably talk
to the back and all the attorneys and all the IRS agents too.
Now, third party communications is not...
not covered under this. Will we do it?
And I'll say to you, big 10.
You want me to talk to these guys or you might say, "Hey, I need you to..."
talk to the bag and it might be for five minutes something that's
really general might be like, let's just do it. We'll make a phone call. No big
feel and just do it as part of the relationship.
It's okay.
But if it's hey I need you to talk to the attorney and he's keeping
on the line for an hour and a half of its high level stuff. Like...
Okay, that'll count right.
So, yeah.
obviously we need to be fair with one another.
or QBO file transfer transition determination.
Everybody can get their file.
I don't know.
Maybe there could be a little bit more language in there.
Here's the deal.
We set up the file and set a QuickBooks Online.
I'm paying for it, but what happens is if you were to ever say
to me. We're done.
I sold it or I just scratched up a lot.
card and I just, you know, I got seven figures something.
I don't need this anymore. Go away and
The reality is I have a subscription.
for your file and I have to end it.
And when I ended it asked for a third party, you know.
to continue the...
the subscription and our descendity.
Like, I'm not gonna shut this.
And even when we shut down--
book files. We literally do like a whole press.
out in the back of the file. So it's not going to go away.
Actually, I just want you to have the file.
If it's--
not working out of your leaving.
I don't want the building on my card.
I need to turn it off and I'll send it to you.
to you. And then it's yours.
Scope by tier.
It's always for meeting.
Notice, okay. So,
Oh, what is this?
Clean matrix.
We have a Matrix. The Matrix is on the...
the is on the proposal.
So the matrix basically is everything we talked about.
included. You got a couple other tiers. I think that
Just a comment again.
I get on a pulpit, maybe you already know.
notice. When you talk to all your customers and clients, give them free
choices. Yeah.
Yeah, absolutely.
positively. It's the quickest way.
I'm sorting out the...
You know, the contenders from pretenders. I'm talented.
Seriously, if they can't pick anything
Then they're not ready for you.
Okay, so I put that.
there. So what we talked about is the core
What's in the middle? Never mind the third tier.
that's pie in the sky. You don't need pie in the sky.
The second tier is IRS.
and New Jersey support.
We have a whole other--
letter, the terms and conditions related to that.
If you sign up for that, you get...
It's just for each year. Any notice?
that comes in later to New Jersey.
We manage.
We take care of 10 hours.
If you don't have a...
If you don't...
have a. Um.
plan with us if you don't pay for it.
Then if you get a notice you can call me and say hey I got a
notice, you know, what do you think? And I'll say
looks like they need X, Y, and Z.
I'll be very objective.
And I'll say it looks like this.
It looks like
2025 you're being audited.
And that's it, you know what I'll say.
is what you got to do and do you want a DIY or
or not. And if you don't have the plan.
and you decide to DIY our
current rate working with the federal auditor.
United States is three and a quarter an hour.
Alright, and I'm doing right now I've got two.
two audits going on right now.
Yeah, so and they didn't go with the
plans and they're paying for it.
So that's how that works.
support. So basically,
it's you push the button I think it's also articulated
in the proposal. You basically can go and I just run your proposal.
So financial statement support like
We're doing, we're parking all the time.
transactions, basic.
giving you a clean general ledger.
for which you can go in and create a P&M.
We'll probably have P&L already out there. We're gonna have a P&L
to balance you out there for you anyway.
And well, you know, 'cause we're in the busy time right now.
It's like...
I probably can't offer that much in terms of like, you know,
Here's a tour of Disney World inside of QuickBooks Online.
Yeah. And this is... I... I...
I'm saying this over and over.
We got a lot of people recovering on board.
It's just a tough time like certainly
and balance it in there.
and I can show you around later on. But you can
go in there. That's your support. You can run a report and there's
drugs.
print it to PDF all that stuff.
Yeah, so let's see service level.
expectations monthly close completion three to four
we said this before three to four weeks.
The months get done basically 3-4 weeks.
the month end. So if everywhere it gets done like the third to fourth week of
and so on.
1099 preparation will do 1099s.
January 31st we send out
like a big bulk email the first week of January.
saying hey here's the spreadsheet throw your 1099s
on there if you want us to file them we'll do it electronically.
See how
sales tax filing. I don't think you have sales tax filing.
Let's see, notice.
audit support. I think we covered all that 10 hour limit hours.
We talked about that, reverent representation and --
Yeah, there's a whole thing that we have like.
for what was covered in that.
if it becomes...
If it comes CIK, which is criminal investigation.
That's not part of this. That's a whole other thing.
You're probably going to need an attorney.
So, termination and trauma.
Like I said, it's 30 days. You can call me in a week.
can say not good and the reality is
We've got so much other stuff going on with good things.
They don't work out it don't work out. It's not a long term for me.
thing you tell me in seven days and if you want to believe in seven days that
It's fine.
This is my practice on the 100%.
owner and it's fine.
and see refund workstoppers.
So this is probably kind of an old thing,
'cause everybody's...
paying for everything in advance. So this is probably
This probably could get paired off after taxis and no f*ck.
Refunds only credit back in the fall time to go
We used to get
Early on.
we would get a refund.
like in three-refunded day. Yeah.
you know, we would get like if we were doing projects.
actually still do if we're doing projects we would get paid and
advance before we start the project.
And then what would happen is like, you know, kind of like you.
like all right well three or four weeks go by and like
If you're doing work and you're making phone calls,
and maybe you're up on something.
Saturday night doing some stuff and then all of a sudden like
you know, early in the week next to somebody says,
well, we're not interested.
just didn't do this with you anymore send us back the money.
Well that's not fair.
and they don't know
what that is. But in your case none of that's happening.
You're actually just paying 20 days after that.
the month we're going to work stop work without client records
include reasonable notice and cure.
Yeah, I mean literally there's no projects here
We're starting with the beginning of the year.
You know, you're--
for January on March the 5th.
literally you should be paying for that.
Everybody paid for it on the 20th of February.
Your peg has fought on March the 3rd. March.
before your next billing site.
it will be marks the 20th.
February and then on and on and on.
on for the next 10 or 50 years.
That's how that works.
So that's really--
You know when I saw this I'm like that's cool like he's gone through all this
stuff and I'm thinking I just had a lot of fun.
You started your business.
I just had a lot of--
Sign up like not in this cool with it.
You know what I mean?
So, but I get it.
I totally get it.
We want to dot the I. So.
Go to my comments.
This is how I'm used to getting on the bottom of my chair.
out is wrong. Just what I want here.
I'm uncomfortable with everything.
Yeah!
Ted, look, you know, I...
I can tell you there's really good energy here.
I think--
you can sense it in a while.
You know, one client isn't going to make or break us.
If it doesn't...
work out. I want it to work out. We'll work to make you.
working out but you know obviously if it doesn't work
you let me know and then there's no hard things.
Mm.
Yeah.
We'll work to transition.
'Cause the reality is,
is in this business is we got a lot of good energy in this way.
what you have to do with all your clients.
Like, you know.
You could do great work for 20 years and all you need is for somebody to say, hey,
He was a real, he was really difficult like at the end.
And then they post something and then all of a sudden, you know, like I
helicopter flying overhead action news with the camera
You're coming down. You know what I'm- (laughs)
Alright, so that's the story with all that.
So if you're cool with everything.
go ahead, sign, make a payment.
We'll get back on the phone.
I want to get the back.
Thanks, setup, and we want to subscribe.
Quick book start getting data to come in
Um, you have a refund.
for 2025 so we don't have to worry about that.
right? Right, because you started your
in January so there's nothing
There's no compliance for...
We're 2025 as everything was just started in 2020.
and also just agree.
You're not an S corporation yet.
Right. I am in the state of Hawaii.
starting to be on February 2nd.
Sorry, I was in the month.
- Got it.
So what I would like--
you to do. You know, so I have for my fight. This is actually
Good for me now and it's good for you and fun.
years when you say, "Where's my certificate of four weeks?"
and EIS. You said that you...
Send those to me. I will put them in our...
permanent file so we'll always have a PDF of them.
And we literally accessed them in five seconds.
Thanks.
Alright, so then that's our plan.
at this time and then we'll talk a little bit.
bit more, you know, once we move toward a
Peace, okay?
of course yeah looking for it to get
and started and yeah any problems with the
what we sent over with the sign and just let me know.
Awesome Timmy, talk to you soon.
Bye, take care. Bye-bye.